on the same pitch but miles apart with
crucial final games this weekend there
was no love lost between liverpool's
jordan henderson and manchester city's
jack grealish
they may not have spoken to each other
or even shook hands but the title
contending midfielders were united for
an inspiring campaign
in the midst of a deepening cost of
living crisis a plan to offer some of
the country's most deprived children the
chance for free and inclusive football
sessions
something england's most expensive
player believes could be life-changing
going back to when i was a young you
know all i ever wanted to do was play
football um and you know even if if i
got this you know to the even the
service you know the playing on here um
it's brilliant uh
and you know if i had this when i was a
a young lad i would have it would have
been my dream making football more
inclusive is at the core of this scheme
something which the sport witnessed this
week after blackpool's jake daniels came
out as gay i think it shows a lot of
courage i'll be honest with you i don't
think there's anyone that that disagrees
with that i think it's absolutely
brilliant and um and like decision i
think it's a massive step forward yeah
how much of a step forward do you think
it is in in the game and how brave do
you think the move was yeah no it is um
you know i've seen that before there was
um
a guy that was playing in australia i
think it was in the in the a league that
um that come out
um and i hope that pushed
um jake daniels you know to to be able
to think you know what i can as well it
wasn't quite when arsenal's beth mead
dreamt of being a footballer 15 years
ago today she relates to the struggles
of many families
to get to training sessions i think it
was an hour to the closest you know
football center for me to play at um
obviously at the time it was with just
boys and
um it was quite isolating for me to get
there and not know anyone get their lit
and not be there consistently
which was difficult outside the national
football museum it was an extra training
session for two of england's top stars
both inspiring future generations
both thinking about writing history this
weekend interim rashid sky news
manchester